Shure: 起床啦
Shure: Time to get up.
Shure: 该起床啦
Shure: Time to wake up.
其他人：好的
Others: Okay.
Shure: 起床起床
Shure: Wake up, wake up.
Shure: Get up, get up.
Jake:用帮忙
Jake: Need some help?
Jake:昨天 发烧了吗困吗
Jake: Did you have a fever yesterday? Tired?
Lucia: 但我有点困
Lucia: But I'm a bit sleepy.
Jake:头疼困
Jake: Headache and tired?
Jake:困困肯定会困
Jake: Sleepy, definitely sleepy.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake:准备戴个眼镜
Jake: Preparing to wear glasses.
Shure: 朝朝暮暮无常烦
Shure: The daily grind is always a hassle.
Jake:没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:这个先放到这儿
Jake: Just put this here for now.
Jake:对对对开就行
Jake: Yes, yes, just turn it on.
Jake:害怕吗
Jake: Are you scared?
Tasha: 害怕吗
Tasha: Are you scared?
爱丽比：那么夸张吗
Alice: Is it that exaggerated?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:好吧给他画一个嘴巴
Jake: Alright, draw a mouth for him.
Jake:他现在他们没有嘴巴
Jake: They don't have mouths now.
Jake:所以还好
Jake: So it's fine.
Jake:不咬人
Jake: They don't bite.
Jake:还有纹身这些狗
Jake: And these dogs have tattoos.
Jake:这些狗都有
Jake: These dogs all have.
Jake:对都有纹身
Jake: Yes, they all have tattoos.
Jake:林子哈哈哈
Jake: Linzi, haha.
Jake:被纸壳封印了起来
Jake: Sealed by cardboard.
Shure: 啊点多吧可能
Shure: Ah, it's probably late.
Shure: 我也不知道起这么早干什么
Shure: I don't know why I'm up so early either.
Shure: 唉你好你好
Shure: Hey, hello, hello.
Shure: 我们中午吃点什么呢
Shure: What should we eat for lunch?
Shure: 明天早上
Shure: Tomorrow morning.
Shure: 明天早上起来第一件事情
Shure: First thing in the morning.
Shure: 就要想吃什么呀
Shure: Think about what to eat.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake: 唉  yes
Jake: Hey, yes.
Shure: 叫床服务已完成
Shure: Wake-up call service completed.
Shure: 想想中午吃什么
Shure: Now, what should we have for lunch?
Shure: 哎呀好香
Shure: Oh, it smells so good.
Jake:今天该吃什么呢
Jake: What should we eat today?
Jake:咱还有啥没吃着的吗
Jake: Is there anything we haven't tried yet?
Jake:传统扎中大中华美食
Jake: Traditional Chinese cuisine.
Shure: 传统扎中大中华美食
Shure: Traditional Chinese cuisine.
Shure: 那
Shure: How about...
Jake:卤煮
Jake: Braised pork.
Shure: 呵呵呵呵
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 这确确实是传统的
Shure: That truly is traditional.
Jake:来一碗吧
Jake: Let's have a bowl.
Shure: 要能点的话
Shure: If it's available.
Shure: 我我是很想吃的
Shure: I'd really love to have it.
Jake:那就点点个卤煮
Jake: Then let's order some braised pork.
Jake:可以多点几个
Jake: We can order a few more dishes.
Jake:要不每人自己点吧
Jake: Or everyone can order their own.
Shure: 也行
Shure: That works too.
Shure: （歌声）在我的怀里
Shure: (Singing) In my arms.
Shure: （歌声）那里春风沉醉那
Shure: (Singing) Where the spring breeze is intoxicating.
Shure: （歌声）绿草如茵
Shure: (Singing) The grass is lush.
Shure: 我很饿呀
Shure: I'm really hungry.
Shure: 我们还有两块牛排没煎呢
Shure: We still have two steaks we haven't cooked.
Shure: 要不煎了吧给他
Shure: How about we cook them?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 这玩意煎好
Shure: Once they're cooked...
Shure: 煎赖反正他是块肉啊也
Shure: Even if they're not perfect, they're still meat.
Jake:行啊上
Jake: Sure, go ahead.
Shure: 把锅刷上
Shure: Scrub the pan.
Shure: 一会把他俩煎了
Shure: We'll cook them in a bit.
Shure: 啊好
Shure: Alright.
Jake:血又掉没了是吧
Jake: Lost your stamina again, right?
Jake:要出去打猎
Jake: Need to go hunting.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Jake:就是饿不行
Jake: Just can't handle the hunger.
Jake:血又掉没了
Jake: Lost your stamina again.
Shure: 是的是的
Shure: Yes, yes.
Jake:又得补啊
Jake: Need to replenish again.
Shure: 得补血啊
Shure: Need to replenish stamina.
Jake:补血
Jake: Replenish stamina.
Shure: （歌声）那里春风沉醉
Shure: (singing) Where the spring breeze intoxicates
Shure: （歌声）那里绿草如茵
Shure: (singing) Where the green grass is lush
Shure: 没有杨老板说不行自个点
Shure: Without Jake saying it's okay, we can't do it ourselves
Shure: 恩
Shure: Yeah
Jake:嗯没有
Jake: Yeah, no
Shure: 喂你好
Shure: Hey, hello
Shure: （通话）无预警通知
Shure: (on the phone) Unannounced notice
Shure: （通话）尊敬的用户截至2024年4月20日11:12
Shure: (on the phone) Dear user, as of April 20, 2024, 11:12
Shure: （通话）您的账号10002826210
Shure: (on the phone) Your account 10002826210
Shure: （通话）您昵称100028262101已欠费3.38元
Shure: (on the phone) Your nickname 100028262101 has an overdue amount of 3.38 yuan
Shure: （通话）您的轻量应用服务器
Shure: (on the phone) Your lightweight application server
Shure: （通话）自定义镜像对向存储算力进阶型
Shure: (on the phone) Custom image storage compute advanced type
Shure: （通话）即将停服
Shure: (on the phone) Will be suspended soon
Shure: 哦我没往你这里充钱卧槽
Shure: Oh, I didn't top up your account, damn it
修硕（通话）：智云资源行服释放通知您好
Shure: (on the phone) Zhiyun resource server release notification, hello
Shure: （通话）截至当前您账号ID哎
Shure: (on the phone) As of now, your account ID, uh
Shure: 我充我充
Shure: I'll top it up, I'll top it up
Shure: 我充你别别急
Shure: I'll top it up, don't worry
Shure: 他妈的我不就忘充了个钱吗
Shure: Damn it, I just forgot to top up the money
Shure: 哎这给你急的
Shure: Geez, you're so anxious about it
Jake:你吃火烧吗
Jake: Do you want some roasted bread?
其他人：还行
Others: It's okay
Jake:卤煮
Jake: Braised pork
Jake:咱有几个吃卤煮的呀
Jake: How many of us are having braised pork?
Jake:早啊
Jake: Morning
Jake:嗨1点 嗨1点
Jake: Hey, a little bit, hey, a little bit
Jake:嗨1点 起床起床曲
Shure: 哈哈快速关门大家
Shure: Haha, quickly close the door, everyone
Shure: 嗨一点
Shure: Hey, a little bit
Jake:大伙是醒呢还是
Jake: Is everyone awake or
Shure: 大伙醒了应该
Shure: Everyone should be awake
Jake:醒了一下是吧
Jake: Just woke up, right?
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay
Jake:醒了但是没完全醒
Jake: Awake but not fully awake
Jake:又睡着了
Jake: Fell back asleep
Shure: 没有都醒了
Shure: No, everyone's awake
Jake:人都喜欢
Jake: Everyone likes it.
Shure: 应该是但是稍微洗洗漱一下吧可能
Shure: Yeah, but maybe wash up a bit first.
Shure: I呢抗打
Shure: I'm resistant.
Shure: 然后发现一个
Shure: And I found a way.
Shure: 可以远程访问我电脑职业数据
Shure: I can remotely access my computer's professional data.
Shure: 然后直接从那里面拿码
Shure: And directly get the code from there.
Shure: 我就不用再下一遍那个数据
Shure: I don't need to download the data again.
Shure: 又省去了一大笔时间
Shure: Saved a lot of time.
Jake:可以
Jake: Nice.
Shure: 他这个真的好慢
Shure: This is really slow.
Shure: 他下载速度只有5啊
Shure: The download speed is only 5.
Shure: 5就是55M你知道吗
Shure: 5 is 55M, you know?
Shure: 就是500KB每秒啊对
Shure: That's 500KB per second, right.
Jake:腾讯云放在国内
Jake: Tencent Cloud is based in China.
Shure: 唉然后这是3块
Shure: Yeah, and it's 3 bucks.
Shure: 3块几一个小时
Shure: 3 bucks something per hour.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake:我点了点卤煮
Jake: I ordered some stewed pork.
Shure: 点了点卤煮
Shure: Stewed pork?
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Jake:开心吗
Jake: Happy?
Shure: 开心太开心
Shure: Super happy!
Shure: 活过来了
Shure: Revived!
Jake:这还有几个
Jake: There's a few more.
Jake:驴肉火烧
Jake: Donkey meat sandwiches.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:还行吧还有啥呀
Jake: Not bad, what else is there?
Shure: 还行
Shure: Not bad.
Jake:还有啥该吃的没吃着啊
Jake: Is there anything we haven't tried yet?
Shure: 想想老北京美食还有什么
Shure: Think about what other old Beijing snacks there are.
Jake:想想
Jake: Think about it.
Shure: 烤鸭吃过了
Shure: We've had roast duck.
Jake:吃了整点热干面吧要不
Jake: Let's have some hot dry noodles, maybe.
Shure: 哈哈对哈哈
Shure: Haha, yeah, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈可以整点
Jake: Hahaha, we could get some.
Jake:有没有啊
Jake: Do they have any?
Jake:北京应该有
Jake: They should have it in Beijing.
Shure: 肯定有
Shure: Definitely.
Jake:不知道外送查查看
Jake: Not sure, let's check delivery.
Shure: 你让武汉人评价一下子
Shure: Let's have a Wuhan person review it.
Jake:热干面咋样啊好吃
Jake: How's the hot dry noodles? Are they good?
Katrina: 麦当劳汉堡
Katrina: McDonald's burger.
Jake:哦晚上吃麦当劳汉堡
Jake: Oh, having McDonald's burger for dinner?
Katrina: 晚上吗晚上
Katrina: For dinner? Yes, for dinner.
Jake:晚上可以吗
Jake: Is dinner okay?
Katrina: 可以中午吃什么中午
Katrina: Sure. What about lunch?
Jake:中午吃卤煮
Jake: Braised pork for lunch.
Lucia: 卤煮啊
Lucia: Braised pork, huh?
Jake:驴肉火烧
Jake: Donkey meat sandwich.
Alice:在弄我的小狗
Alice: I'm handling my puppy.
Shure: 哈哈哈你要不点点点
Shure: Haha, why don't you order something else?
Lucia: 不吃卤煮不吃卤煮
Lucia: No braised pork, no braised pork.
Shure: 点那个在清清小清新一点的东西
Shure: Order something lighter and fresher.
Jake:那几家店没有小清新的东西
Jake: Those places don't have anything light and fresh.
Lucia: 不吃卤煮
Lucia: No braised pork.
Jake:那火烧火烧吃吗
Jake: How about the sandwich? Want it?
Jake:驴肉火烧
Jake: Donkey meat sandwich.
Jake:牛肉火烧呢
Jake: How about beef sandwich?
Shure: 尝尝你就知道
Shure: Try it, you'll see.
Jake:就是饼就是饼
Jake: It's just a pancake.
Jake:点几个煎饼吧
Jake: Let's order some pancakes.
Jake:要不就山东煎饼天津煎饼
Jake: Either Shandong pancakes or Tianjin pancakes.
Shure: 天津的吧应该是
Shure: Tianjin ones, I guess.
Jake:天津
Jake: Tianjin.
Alice:这个还有面包
Alice: There's also bread.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:下面我给你拿上来
Jake: I'll bring it up for you.
Jake:或者你下去好嘞
Jake: Or you can come down. Okay.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:你有擦眼镜的布吗
Jake: Do you have a cloth for cleaning glasses?
Katrina: 没有
Katrina: No.
Shure: 你要喝吗
Shure: Do you want a drink?
Shure: 咖啡
Shure: Coffee.
Shure: 好
Shure: Sure.
Shure: 他踩井盖
Shure: He stepped on a manhole cover.
Shure: 这个是文化差异了属于
Shure: This is a cultural difference.
Shure: 叫什么你知道ADHD这个这个病吗
Shure: Do you know about ADHD, that condition?
Shure: 叫什么
Shure: What's it called?
Jake:ADHD
Jake: ADHD.
Shure: 注意力缺陷什么的那种
Shure: Attention deficit or something.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Shure: 就是像我现在这个样子
Shure: Just like how I am right now.
Shure: 拿到什么东西就开始甩
Shure: Grabbing anything and start tossing it around.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake:哈
Shure: 我这个可以作为那个病例参考的
Shure: I could be a case study for this condition.
Shure: 珍贵影像
Shure: Valuable footage.
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake:怎么了
Jake: What's wrong?
Jake:打不开
Jake: Can't open it.
Tasha: 就先用这个吧
Jake:插个电就打开了
Jake: Just plug it in and it will turn on.
Tasha: 啊啊
Jake:插电即开即插
Jake: Plug it in and it will turn on immediately.
Tasha: 这个这是
Jake:因为这是我的充电宝
Jake: Because this is my power bank.
Jake:你先开了
Jake: You turn it on first.
Jake:你开了可以再领一个充电宝对
Jake: Once you turn it on, you can get another power bank, right.
Jake:对就是这样
Jake: Yes, that's how it works.
Tasha: 我们中午吃什么
Jake:呃点了
Jake: Uh, ordered.
Tasha: 卤煮
Alice: Lu Zhu.
Jake:可能再过10分钟吧
Jake: Maybe in another 10 minutes.
Jake:就有牛肉火烧吃了
Jake: We'll have beef stuffed buns.
Jake:牛肉火烧
Jake: Beef stuffed buns.
Jake:我怎么我没怎么吃过
Jake: I haven't had it much.
Jake:你吃的多吗
Jake: Do you eat it often?
Shure: 我吃也不多
Shure: I don't eat it much either.
Jake:哦那挺好
Jake: Oh, that's good.
Shure: 还行吧
Shure: It's okay.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 完了哈哈
Shure: Oh no, haha.
Jake:你昨天都是0418
Jake: Yesterday, it was all 0418.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Shure: 不行看时间戳
Shure: No, check the timestamp.
Shure: 改一下吧杨老板
Shure: Change it, Jake.
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Hmm, okay, good book.
Jake:这个好书
Jake: This is a good book.
Tasha: 哎呦好脏呀
Tasha: Oh, it's so dirty.
Tasha: 眼睛布呢
Tasha: Where's the cloth for my eyes?
Alice:小狗狗的鼻子小狗狗的嘴
Alice: Little dog's nose, little dog's mouth.
Jake:呀你昨天全给你了
Jake: Yeah, I gave you everything yesterday.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 因为你说这样就不用发我的工资了
Tasha: Because you said that way you don't have to pay my salary.
Jake:哦确实
Jake: Oh, indeed.
Tasha: 你不就是这个意思吗
Tasha: Isn't that what you meant?
Jake:是这个意思人挺好
Jake: Yes, that's what I meant, nice person.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Jake:开了吗
Jake: Did it bloom?
小薇 ：开了吗
Tasha: Did it bloom?
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake:咱今整点啥
Jake: What are we doing today?
Tasha: 做啥都可以
Tasha: We can do anything.
Jake:要做多少要做多少
Jake: How much should we do? How much should we do?
Tasha: 做多少都可以
Tasha: We can do as much as you want.
Jake:东西
Jake: Stuff.
Jake:做多少都可以
Jake: We can do as much as you want.
Tasha: 现在开始做也可以
Tasha: We can start now.
Jake:得做啊，还挺多的
Jake: We have to do it, there's quite a lot.
Tasha: 对做做
Tasha: Yeah, let's do it.
Tasha: 你想吃什么
Tasha: What do you want to eat?
Jake:嗯还有啥没做的吗
Jake: Hmm, is there anything we haven't made yet?
Tasha: 芋头芋头吃不了了
Tasha: The taro, we can't eat it anymore.
Jake:芋头啊好嘞
Jake: Taro, okay.
Tasha: 芋头到不了了
Tasha: The taro didn't arrive.
Jake:为啥呀
Jake: Why?
Shure: 请塔莎老师
Shure: Let's ask Tasha.
Shure: 咖啡
Shure: Coffee.
Tasha: 怎么了哦
Tasha: What's up, oh.
Jake:傻傻的咖啡
Jake: Silly coffee.
Shure: 烫烫烫烫烫嗯
Shure: Hot, hot, hot, hmm.
Tasha: 怎么是热的
Tasha: Why is it hot?
Jake:放点冰块
Jake: Put some ice cubes in it.
Jake:呵咱冰块是说要买是吧
Jake: Oh, did we say we need to buy ice cubes?
Shure: 两冰块是朋友买的
Shure: Our friend bought two ice cubes.
Katrina: 美团
Katrina: Meituan.
Shure: 冰块有
Shure: We have ice cubes.
Jake:冰块有有了
Jake: We have ice cubes now?
Jake:是吗哪了好买了是吧
Jake: Really? Where? Did you buy them?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Tasha: 哪呢
Tasha: Where?
Shure: 在楼下的那个冰格里
Shure: In the ice tray downstairs.
Tasha: 哦冰格里是吗
Tasha: Oh, in the ice tray?
Shure: 是吗不是
Shure: Is it? No.
Shure: 就上次你想起来没
Shure: Last time, do you remember?
Katrina: 你美团送
Katrina: Did you order from Meituan?
Katrina: 送的那一坨
Katrina: The thing they gave us.
Shure: 对凑单
Shure: Yeah, to make up the order.
Shure: 然后我凑了一袋冰
Shure: And then I added a bag of ice.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 你要吗
Tasha: Do you want it?
Shure: 你用吗我不用
Shure: Do you need it? I don't.
Shure: 你先用吧
Shure: You use it first.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:好加冰
Jake: Alright, add ice.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 洗葡萄
Shure: Wash the grapes.
Tasha: 算了不能加
Tasha: Forget it, we can't add it.
Shure: 你洗你葡萄
Shure: You wash your grapes.
Shure: 我冲我的咖啡
Shure: I'll brew my coffee.
Tasha: 不能喝冰
Tasha: Can't drink anything cold.
Jake:你不要
Jake: You don't need it.
Jake:你你你又不是直接视频
Jake: You, you, you're not even on the video directly.
Shure: 这可以丢掉
Shure: This can be thrown away.
Shure: 其实你先给他放那放那吧先
Shure: Actually, just put it there for now.
Shure: 然后一会丢了
Shure: And then we can toss it later.
Shure: 记得我们有这个有这个
Shure: Remember, we have this, we have this.
Shure: 要丢的东西
Shure: Stuff to be thrown away.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Tasha: 我又让你破房了
Tasha: I made you break the house again.
Shure: 怎么不满了
Shure: What's the problem?
Tasha: 是的我让杨老板也破房
Tasha: Yes, I made Jake break the house too.
Shure: 站你旁边碍你眼了是吗
Shure: Standing next to you is bothering you, huh?
Katrina: 哈哈我要摔碟子骂人了
Katrina: Haha, I'm going to smash plates and curse now.
Shure: 大人
Shure: Adult stuff.
Katrina: 太阳好好啊
Katrina: The sun is so nice.
Katrina: 又要洗衣服
Katrina: Time to do laundry again.
Shure: 要骂厨子的是吗
Shure: Are you going to curse at the chef?
Katrina: 还养的多吗
Katrina: Are they raising a lot?
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina: 之前看人家说亲戚家养乐多
Katrina: I saw someone saying their relatives are raising a lot.
Katrina: 捣捣捣捣把它捣碎那种很爽
Katrina: Smash, smash, smash, smashing it feels so good.
Katrina: 那这个要留着明天
Katrina: This one should be saved for tomorrow.
Katrina: 哈哈等会再买
Katrina: Haha, buy it again later.
Katrina: 好像今天要叫外送
Katrina: Seems like we need to order food delivery today.
Tasha: 嗯
Shure: 对可以直接点盒马外送的其实
Katrina: 明天还需要再买
Shure: （歌声 ）月光白莲
Katrina: 这是在干什么
Katrina: What are we doing here?
Shure: 磨豆子
Shure: Grinding beans.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Shure: 磨豆子
Shure: Grinding beans.
Katrina: 哦哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh.
Katrina: 这个是民宿自带的吗
Katrina: Is this provided by the B&B?
Shure: 是明星自带吗
Shure: Did a celebrity bring this?
Katrina: 还你带过来的
Katrina: Or did you bring it?
Shure: 什么哪个
Shure: What? Which one?
Shure: 这个这这套
Shure: This one, this set.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Shure: 这套是自带过来的
Shure: This set was brought over.
Shure: 哼
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 但我今天早上起来也搞了一些
Shure: But I did some work this morning too.
Shure: 因为我一直还有个东西没跑
Shure: Because I still have something to run.
Shure: 然后今天早上买了个服务器
Shure: And I bought a server this morning.
Shure: 然后去跑了一下去
Shure: Then I went for a run.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Jake:我想想
Jake: Let me think.
Shure: 腾讯云的那个真那下载速忒慢了
Shure: The download speed from Tencent Cloud is really slow.
Shure: 他那服务器给的下载速
Shure: The server's download speed is just...
Shure: 那个贷款就5张
Shure: That loan is just for 5 items.
Shure: 然后下东西就他妈500K我靠
Shure: And the download speed is just 500K, damn.
Katrina: 要他们开会员是不是
Katrina: Do we need to get them to open a membership?
Katrina: 或者是要买
Katrina: Or need to buy?
Shure: 不是不是不是开会员
Shure: No, no, it's not about the membership.
Katrina: 要买
Katrina: Need to buy.
Katrina: 还说他本来就这么
Katrina: Or is it always like this?
Shure: 他他他就
Shure: He just...
Shure: 就只有那么那么那么大的下行
Shure: The download speed is just that slow.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Shure: 下行速度
Shure: Download speed.
Katrina: 那他不怕倒闭吗
Katrina: Aren't they afraid of going bankrupt?
Shure: 很奇怪
Shure: It's weird.
Shure: 他们卡还可以
Shure: Their cards are okay.
Lucia: 让我们看看今天的转化率有多少
Lucia: Let's see how much the conversion rate is today.
Jake:好称一下
Jake: Okay, let's weigh it.
Lucia: 啊在这
Lucia: Ah, here it is.
Jake:哈哈好嘞
Jake: Haha, got it.
Lucia: 我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Shure: 那个拿一个包
Shure: Grab a bag.
Shure: 躲在我这屋干什么呢
Shure: What are you hiding in my room for?
Lucia: 给您清好铃了
Lucia: I've cleaned the bell for you.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Shure: 这是什么
Shure: What's this?
Lucia: 你可以先把盘子放在上面
Lucia: You can put the plate on it first.
Lucia: 然后清一下铃
Lucia: Then clear the bell.
Lucia: 然后再称它
Lucia: Then weigh it again.
其他人：给我们的货币上链真的吗
Others: Are we really putting our currency on the blockchain?
Lucia: 就是要把这些拿起来
Lucia: You just need to pick these up.
Lucia: 我已经学会了
Lucia: I've learned it already.
Lucia: 薇薇如何使用这个秤
Lucia: Tasha, how to use this scale?
Shure: 那我们这叫什么币
Shure: What do we call this currency?
Lucia: 就是好像有点有点不平
Lucia: It's kind of, kind of uneven.
Tasha: 怎么安装它呢
Tasha: How to install it?
Shure: 真的叫Eagle Coin是吗
Shure: Is it really called Eagle Coin?
Lucia: 我们还是在这里吧
Lucia: Let's just stay here.
Jake:对就在这就在这
Jake: Yes, right here, right here.
Shure: 我操
Shure: Damn.
Lucia: 就是您可以先把这个盘子放上来
Lucia: So you can place this plate here first.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 然后把芒果拿走
Lucia: Then take the mango away.
Lucia: 哇这盘子这么重
Lucia: Wow, this plate is so heavy.
Shure: 哈哈哈好的
Shure: Hahaha, okay.
Jake:哎我好像有快递
Jake: Hey, I think I have a delivery.
Lucia: 青柠嗯好
Lucia: Lime, okay.
Tasha: 明天就是最后一天了
Tasha: Tomorrow is the last day.
Lucia: 然后哎您又碰到了
Lucia: And, hey, you touched it again.
Jake:我有快递到了
Jake: My delivery has arrived.
Shure: 这会有实际价值是吗
Shure: Does this have actual value?
Lucia: 嗯又有快递到了
Lucia: Hmm, another delivery.
Alice:明天倒数第二天
Alice: Tomorrow is the second last day.
Shure: 他说他从7天开始
Shure: He said he started from day 7.
Jake:呃应该是外卖驴肉火烧
Jake: Uh, it should be donkey meat sandwich.
Alice:周一不是还有干嘛什么的
Alice: Isn't there something on Monday?
Lucia: OK OK
Lucia: OK, OK.
Jake:没吃过卤煮
Jake: Never tried stewed intestine.
Shure: 货币价值就已经在使用了
Shure: The currency value is already in use.
Tasha: 周一好像就是收尾了
Tasha: Monday seems to be the wrap-up.
Lucia: 没有真没有
Lucia: No, really no.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Shure: 取决于我们现场的工序关系
Shure: It depends on our on-site procedures.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake:哎你好哎你好外卖到
Jake: Hey, hello, hello, delivery is here.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake:了哎好
Jake: Alright, great.
Alice:周一晚上走还是周二
Alice: Leaving Monday night or Tuesday?
Jake:来了来了来了来了来了
Jake: It's here, it's here, it's here.
Jake:你在哪啊
Jake: Where are you?
Shure: 卧槽这么高级吗
Shure: Wow, is it this fancy?
Jake:（电话）在门口那个
Jake: (On the phone) At the entrance.
Tasha: 嗯不太知道呢
Tasha: Hmm, not really sure.
Jake:（电话）我看到有个53号啊
Jake: (On the phone) I see a number 53.
Jake:好呃别别别别动啊53号呃
Jake: Alright, uh, don't move, number 53, uh.
Katrina: 23号约了晚饭
Katrina: Dinner is scheduled for the 23rd.
Shure: 这今天怪不得心情这么好
Shure: No wonder you're in such a good mood today.
Katrina: 居然不喜欢吃小龙虾
Katrina: Surprisingly, you don't like eating crayfish.
Katrina: 这让我很生气
Katrina: That makes me really angry.
Shure: 要是喜欢吃小龙虾可以去那个湖大
Shure: If you like crayfish, you can go to that lake.
Katrina: 吃不到一块去生气
Katrina: I'm angry we can't enjoy food together.
Shure: 吃不到一块去分了吧
Shure: If you can't enjoy food together, just break up.
Shure: 呵呵呵呵
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina: 怎么没开始呢
Katrina: Why hasn't it started yet?
Katrina: 太没品了这人
Katrina: This person is so tasteless.
Shure: 太没品
Shure: So tasteless.
Shure: 真的谈不了一点
Shure: Can't even talk a bit.
Katrina: 还不是牛蛙真的是
Katrina: It's not even bullfrog, seriously.
Shure: 那你们想吃什么
Shure: So what do you guys want to eat?
Katrina: 非要吃潮汕牛肉
Katrina: We have to eat Chaoshan beef.
Shure: 哈哈哈好
Shure: Hahaha, alright.
Shure: 北欧旁边那个叫什么
Shure: What's the name of that place next to Northern Europe?
Shure: 巴河里还有哪一个来着
Shure: And what's the other one by the Ba River?
Shure: 都特别好吃
Shure: They're all really delicious.
Katrina: 之前他带我吃过金谷园
Katrina: He took me to Jin Gu Yuan before.
Shure: 潮汕羊肉
Shure: Chaoshan lamb.
Shure: 这是我们北欧特色
Shure: This is our Northern Europe specialty.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 还带我吃了一个你们旁边的一家涮肉
Katrina: He also took me to a hot pot place near your place.
Katrina: 就海淀对面
Katrina: Just across from Haidian.
Shure: 西直门那个吗
Shure: The one at Xizhimen?
Shure: 西什么西直门
Shure: Xi what, Xizhimen?
Katrina: 西什么我不知道
Katrina: I don't know, Xi something.
Katrina: 反正就你们学校走出来一会就到了
Katrina: Anyway, it's just a short walk from your school.
Shure: 那我不知道那个
Shure: Well, I don't know about that one.
Shure: 我每次都去那个西直门那个
Shure: I always go to that one at Xizhimen.
Shure: 洋访胜利
Shure: Yangfang Victory.
Katrina: 没有心情很好啊
Katrina: No, I'm in a good mood.
Katrina: 我吗
Katrina: Me?
Katrina: 只是因为我今天睡饱了
Katrina: It's just because I had enough sleep today.
Katrina: 我今天没定闹钟
Katrina: I didn't set an alarm today.
Katrina: 因为我看昨天晚上没有说今天几点
Katrina: Because I saw no one mentioned the time for today last night.
Shure: 嘴角比AK还难压
Shure: Harder to keep a straight face than AK.
Katrina: 喊出喊出来吃饭还是很简单的
Katrina: Calling everyone out to eat is still pretty easy.
Katrina: 说还是很怪
Katrina: But it still sounds weird.
Shure: 问其他的一律不答
Shure: If you ask anything else, I won't answer.
Shure: 吃饭吧吃
Shure: Let's eat.
Shure: 哈哈哈呦喂
Shure: Hahaha, oh dear.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈对你总觉得好到位
Katrina: Hahaha, yeah, you always get it just right.
Shure: （歌声）那里春风沉醉
Shure: (singing) There where the spring breeze is intoxicating
Jake:来负责一下
Jake: Come on, take charge
Jake:分一分
Jake: Divide it up
Katrina: 点的什么呀
Katrina: What did you order?
Jake:这个他路上撒了卤煮
Jake: He spilled some braised food on the way
Jake:撒的很
Jake: Spilled a lot
Jake:可以撒的很卤煮越来越看越想吃了
Jake: He spilled a lot, the more I look at it, the more I want to eat it
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Damn
Shure: 哼哼哼
Shure: Humming
Lucia: 所以它是一种冒菜吗
Lucia: So is it some kind of spicy hot pot?
Shure: 是no no no
Shure: No no no
Jake:是
Jake: Yes
Shure: 这乳乳闻着下水味就有点重
Shure: This braised food smells kind of strong
Jake:是
Jake: Yes
Jake:下水味重是吧
Jake: It smells strong, right?
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly
Lucia: 什么它里面是下水吗
Lucia: What, is it made with offal?
Lucia: 不是它是用下水做的吗
Lucia: No, is it made with offal?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Jake:就是硬煮
Jake: It's just hard-boiled
Lucia: 硬煮
Lucia: Hard-boiled
Jake:就是煮啊煮煮煮直接煮
Jake: Just boil it, boil, boil, boil, directly boil
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay
Shure: 这其实
Shure: Actually
Jake:其实
Jake: Actually
Shure: 分两个人分吃吧
Shure: Let's split it between two people
Shure: 或者三个人
Shure: Or three people
Shure: 或者自己每个人拿个小碗接着吃吧
Shure: Or everyone take a small bowl and keep eating
Jake:拿小碗接着吃
Jake: Take a small bowl and keep eating
Shure: 对行
Shure: Right, okay
Jake:你多整点小碗我找不着碗
Jake: Get more small bowls, I can't find any
Shure: 要不找不着碗
Shure: Or we can't find the bowls.
Shure: 行那去楼下吃
Shure: Fine, let's eat downstairs.
Shure: 楼上吃
Shure: Or upstairs.
Lucia: 我看一下楼下的桌子现在情况怎么样
Lucia: I'll check the tables downstairs and see how they're doing.
Lucia: 应该大家都把
Lucia: Everyone should have...
Jake:很不怎么样哈哈哈哈哦这样
Jake: Not too great, hahaha, oh like this.
Lucia: 呃不是大家都把花搬走了吗
Lucia: Uh, didn't everyone move the flowers already?
Shure: 那在楼上吃吧
Shure: Then let's eat upstairs.
Shure: 然后把那个电脑收一下
Shure: And pack up that computer.
Shure: 我的室友们给点力呀
Shure: Come on, roommates, let's do this!
Shure: 不是我在呼唤我
Shure: No, I'm calling my...
Shure: 我真实的室友们
Shure: My real roommates.
Katrina: 这是北京特产吗
Katrina: Is this a specialty from Beijing?
Shure: 这是北京特产吗
Shure: Is this a specialty from Beijing?
Shure: 这是北京嘎嘎特产
Shure: This is a super specialty from Beijing.
Shure: 卧槽第
Shure: Oh, damn...
Shure: 一次吃的时候我根本接受不了
Shure: I couldn't handle it when I first ate it.
Shure: 但是越吃越香
Shure: But the more you eat, the more delicious it gets.
Shure: 但是这家闻着不正宗
Shure: But this place doesn't smell authentic.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Katrina: 主人你怎么一股大肠味
Katrina: Master, why do you smell like intestines?
Shure: 对啊他就是啊
Shure: Yeah, exactly.
Shure: 你不吃大肠
Shure: You don't eat intestines?
Shure: 他还有那什么
Shure: He also has that...
Shure: 他还有
Shure: He also has...
Shure: 其他的他还点了驴肉火烧
Shure: Besides that, he also ordered donkey meat buns.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 就是类似于一种肉夹馍吧
Shure: It's kind of like a meat sandwich.
Katrina: 哎我靠
Katrina: Oh my god.
Shure: 怎么早餐不不喝公主心意了是吗
Shure: Why aren't you having the princess's choice for breakfast anymore?
Katrina: 不是不是
Katrina: No, no.
Shure: 不是这是早餐
Shure: No, this is breakfast.
Katrina: 这是早餐
Katrina: This is breakfast.
Shure: 对哎呀差不多
Shure: Yeah, it's pretty much the same.
Katrina: 不是我觉得好尴尬
Katrina: No, I feel so awkward.
Katrina: 我不想去那个说好奇怪
Katrina: I don't want to go there, it's so weird.
Jake:31难找谢谢
Jake: 31 is hard to find, thanks.
Shure: （歌声 ）那里春风沉醉
Shure: (singing) Where the spring breeze is intoxicating.
Shure: （歌声 ）那里绿草如茵
Shure: (singing) Where the green grass is like a carpet.
Shure: （歌声 ）多少年以后
Shure: (singing) Many years later...
Shure: 浮云般游走
Shure: Wandering like a floating cloud.
Shure: 刷点碗吧出来
Shure: Wash some dishes and come out.
Shure: 可以上去吃
Shure: We can go up to eat.
Shure: 准备上去吧
Shure: Let's get ready to go up.
Jake:我要转化帮我提谢谢
Jake: I need to convert, help me carry it, thanks.
Shure: 然后呢
Shure: And then?
Jake:我转化一下
Jake: I'll convert it.
Shure: go
Shure: Go.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:这个不测转化率呢
Jake: This doesn't test conversion rate?
Lucia: 测好了嗯
Lucia: It's tested, yeah.
Jake:测好了哦
Jake: It's tested, oh.
Lucia: 他一个反正刚才的那个是89克
Lucia: The one just now was 89 grams.
Jake:哦让我在这操作是吧
Jake: Oh, you want me to operate here, right?
Lucia: 相当于这个
Lucia: Equivalent to this.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 这个屋子味都杂了你知道吗
Shure: The smell in this room is mixed, you know?
Shure: 往右扭头是咖啡味
Shure: Turn your head right, it's coffee smell.
Shure: 往左扭头是大肠味呵呵呵
Shure: Turn your head left, it's intestine smell, haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina: 把我房间关起来
Katrina: Close my room door.
Shure: 有现成的可以喝一下什么咖啡吗
Shure: Is there any ready-made coffee we can drink?
Alice:现成的可以喝一下了吗
Alice: Is there any ready-made coffee we can drink?
Shure: 可以喝
Shure: Yes, you can drink it.
Shure: 找个杯子倒一点就可以
Shure: Just find a cup and pour a little.